sulfates fatty alcohols silicones preservatives
why are they in shampoo and conditioner
and do you need to avoid them
hi i'm michelle chemistry phd and
cosmetic chemist today we're doing
a deep dive into some of the key
ingredients in hair care products
this video was sponsored by the ordinary
who turned a lot of people into skincare
nerds with their focus on ingredients
and now they're moving into hair care
let's start with shampoo
to me the best way to approach
analyzing formulas is to think
what is the point of this
product what is its function
shampoo obviously cleans your hair
and scalp just like skin your scalp
produces sebum which we usually think of as oil
this oil keeps your skin and scalp nice and
soft and it also travels along the hair to
keep that soft as well but sometimes we have
too much oil some of us like me more than others
it also tends to stick to things like
dirt dust skin flakes and pollution
you might also use styling
products that need to be washed off
the problem is if you just try to use
water to degreasify everything a bit
it usually doesn't work very well because
oil and water don't mix so to make them mix
we use a shampoo and the key ingredients
in the shampoo that clean are surfactants
surfactants are really useful ingredients because
they have a head that likes water and a tail that
likes oil and so instead of repelling each other
the surfactants allow the oil to basically be
smuggled into the water in lots of tiny droplets
and then you can wash that away down the drain
there are surfactants in tons of
different products because getting
oil and water to stay together is really useful
for cleaning the best surfactants are anionic
surfactants these have a negatively charged head
and they're used in tons of cleaning
products shampoo obviously but also
laundry detergent dishwashing detergent
body washes and face cleansers
some of the anionic surfactants
that you might have seen in your
shampoos and cleansers are sulfates
sarcosinates taurates and isethionates
traditional soaps also have anionic
surfactants called carboxylates
so that's what the sulfates are doing but
why are people talking about sulfate-free
well a lot of it is based on misinformation once
you start digging into the science behind shampoos
you start to realize that limiting yourself to
sulfate-free shampoos doesn't really make sense
sulfate surfactants are a diverse group of
ingredients that behave in different ways
and on top of that they can be
combined in formulas in lots
of different ways to give very different shampoos
it's a bit like eggs in a recipe just
seeing eggs in the ingredients list
doesn't tell you whether they used
the whites or the yolks or a mix
how the food tastes or whether you'll
like it unless you have an egg allergy
in which case you probably should avoid it
unless you really like pain or you're vegan
so generalizing sulfates in products
doesn't really work it isn't like
shampoos with sulfates are always harsher
or more irritating or strip colour faster than
sulfate-free shampoos there is a lot of overlap
sulfates are some of the most commonly used
anionic surfactants in personal care products
the two you'll see most in shampoos
are sodium lauryl sulfate sls
and sodium laureth sulfate sles these sound
pretty similar but they're actually very different
sodium lauryl sulfate is the more
famous one and it has a bad reputation
which has now spread to other
sulfates it has a narrow structure
and that means it can potentially absorb into
skin more easily and keep irritating for longer
if sls is in a formula on its own in a
high concentration then it will probably
be quite irritating and this is one of the big
reasons why it has this irritant reputation
a lot of the time in peer-reviewed
studies and in dermatology patch testing
sls is used by itself to make sure it is the
specific ingredient that someone is reacting to
but this also means it isn't in
its usual environment which is
in a product with a lot of other ingredients that
change how it interacts with skin and with hair
there are lots of formulating tricks that are
usually used in sls products here are some of them
creating mixed micelles by combining sls with
other surfactants this makes sls less likely to
wander off on its own into your skin or hair
it's like peer pressure but for molecules
adding polymers that act as a raft
to hold onto free sls molecules
again this is so it can't run
away into your skin or hair
adding skin protecting ingredients
like humectants and antioxidants
that can prevent or reverse some of the irritation
now sles sodium laureth sulfate actually
isn't one single ingredient it's actually a
category of ingredients that are all listed
under the same name in an ingredients list
ingredient lists don't really lie but they
don't really tell you the full story either
sles is ethoxylated which means it's sls but
with a bunch of ethoxy units inserted next to the
sulfur like this the number of units can change
and this changes how the specific type of sles
interacts with everything else water
oil or other surfactant molecules
having these ethoxy units means that less
sles will wander off on its own into your skin
compared to sls ethoxylation
also makes the molecule bigger
which means it doesn't penetrate
skin as easily and is more gentle
it's a bit like walking through a crowd if
you want to get through a crowd faster you
try to hunch and make yourself
smaller you don't spread your arms out
there's one study that found that sles was
gentler than sls which is not very surprising
but it was also gentler than a whole bunch
of non-sulfate surfactants that you
often find in sulfate-free products
and on top of this formulators
can use the same formulating
tricks that i mentioned before to
make sles products even gentler
now with color fading i have a strong personal
interest in this as you can probably tell
when i first dyed my hair four years
ago i used sulfate-free shampoos because
that's what everyone says is best for
keeping your hair colour for longer
except i hated all the sulfate-free shampoos
that i tried and i spent a lot of money on
them because i went with a lot of very fancy
brands i ended up just going back to sulphate
shampoos and i didn't actually notice much
of a difference with my hair colour fading
recently i got to see some experimental data on
colour fading that confirmed what i noticed
happening with my hair with colour fading
there are some differences between different
shampoo formulas as you'd expect from everything
i've said so far there is a lot of overlap
between sulfate-ful and sulfate-free shampoos
the ph of the shampoo actually made a bigger
difference than whether or not it had sulfates
higher ph more alkaline shampoos
will leach some dyes out faster
but by far the biggest thing
that made a difference was
just water just washing coloured hair in water
without shampoo leaches out a ton of dye the
differences between different shampoos are
tiny compared to washing versus not washing
so my problem was that a lot of sulfate-free
shampoos were formulated to be too gentle to
clean my scalp and hair properly i have
a pretty oily scalp and so that meant
that i either washed my hair every day or i just
suffered with sticky limp hair and an itchy scalp
and sometimes that happened even if i washed daily
using a shampoo with sulfates
let me wash my hair less often
and so i actually ended up with less fading
sulfates are also quite cheap which
a lot of people paint as a bad thing
that companies are just using
cheap ingredients to save money
even though there might be better more
expensive options and this does happen
but it's never the only reason
formulators use a particular ingredient
number one you have to make a product
that works the cheapest ingredient is
just water but if a company tried to sell plain
water as a product it would flop really hard
number two price doesn't directly
match with quality i'm sure we all
have a favorite cheap meal that we'd happily
pick over a bunch of more expensive options
and shout out to this video's sponsor
the ordinary most of us have probably
tried some super budget-friendly
skincare products from the ordinary
that worked better than more expensive ones
and sulfates do actually have some really
good properties that make them great in
cleansing products on top of just
the price of the raw material one
of the reasons sulfates work out to be
cheap is because they're multifunctional
obviously they clean really well
but they also foam well more foam
doesn't actually mean a better
clean but psychologically if
there isn't that much foam most people
just don't think it's doing a good job
sulfates also help create a thicker texture
and you can usually add a bit of salt to make
a sulfate product thicken even more shampoos need
to be a little bit thick so it sits nicely in your
hand and you can get it onto your hair effectively
it also makes it feel more concentrated
a lot of other surfactants
don't have these properties so
if you take out the sulfates you often have
to add in a bunch of other ingredients to
boost the foam and make it
thicker which adds to the cost
let's take a look at the ordinary sulphate
4% cleanser for body and hair which is
a pretty stripped back shampoo formula
sodium laureth sulfate is the anionic
surfactant it's at four percent which
you can hopefully tell from the name this is
pretty low for shampoo but this also doubles up
as a body wash which normally has
lower amounts so this keeps it gentle
specifically they're using sles-2
which means there's two ethoxy units
per molecule this is the most common
type used in shampoos because it gives a good
balance between cleaning gentleness and cost
apart from the anionic surfactant
we have some other ingredients
water is the first ingredient
and that's pretty important
it keeps the surfactants spread out the right
way when you put them on your hair or skin
if it's too concentrated it's really harsh you
do not want 100% surfactant on your skin or your
hair trust me getting the right dilution
also affects the thickness of the shampoo
polysorbate 20 is another surfactant it's
not as good at cleaning and it's usually
used as a solubilizer so it might be in
there to help the tocopherol dissolve
xanthan gum is a thickener
that makes the texture thicker
tocopherol is vitamin e which is an antioxidant
there's a mix of preservatives which stops the
bacteria and mould from having a fun
multiplying festival inside the shampoo
you need a preservative whenever
you have a water-based formula
there are chelating agents which grab onto metal
ions metal ions can make anionic surfactants work
worse especially when there's hard water chelating
agents also help preservatives work better
like i said this is a relatively simple formula
so in other shampoos you'll
have other ingredients too
you might have other surfactants because
combining multiple surfactants can make
a cleanser more gentle some of them
can also boost foam or moisturize skin
shampoos also often have detangling
ingredients because when hair is wet
the cuticle sticks up more so the surface
is rougher and it can snag on other hairs
more easily so most shampoos will have some
ingredients that very thinly coat the hair
to make a smoothing layer the most common
ingredients for these are polyquaterniums
sometimes you'll also see colorants fragrances and
pearlizing agents to make the
shampoo look and smell nicer
my scalp gets dry and irritated
from a lot of shampoos so
i was pretty curious to see how this
very simple formula would go for me
this turned out to be really good for my scalp
one of the better tolerated shampoos i've used
having multiple surfactants is usually
good because it reduces irritation
but they've gotten around this by using
a low percentage of a gentle type of sles
there also isn't any fragrance in this i
personally like a bit of fragrance in my
hair products but i know a lot of people want
or need to avoid it it's actually pretty hard
to find fragrance-free hair products so i'm
really happy to see this available as an option
now onto hair conditioners hair
conditioners have a few more
functions than shampoo and different
people use them for different purposes
if you have short hair you might
not actually need hair conditioner
conditioners can add shine smooth
over damage and reduce tangling
and static to do this they leave a
very thin coating on hair strands
there is this myth that cheap
conditioners will coat hair
but expensive ones don't this is not
true you need a coating because your
hair is dead and as it grows it accumulates
damage and ends up looking chipped like this
hair conditioner smooth over this
roughness by plugging in the gaps
so hair doesn't snag and cause
more of these bits to break off
the main ingredients used in hair conditioners
are cationic surfactants these are a lot like
the anionic surfactants we saw in shampoos
except they have a positively charged head
when hair is wet it gets a negative charge
and the damaged bits of hair usually have
a stronger negative charge opposite
charges attract and so these positive
heads in the cationic surfactants help
them stick to the negatively charged hair
the positive charges are also handy because
once you have enough attached the hair becomes
slightly positive which will actually repel
extra cationic surfactants what this means
is you end up with a thinner more even film
that feels silky rather than the sort of film
that you might get with a lot of oils like your
natural hair oil that's heavy and weighs hair down
the most common type of cationic
surfactant that you'll see in conditioners
are quaternary ammonium ions nicknamed quats
you'll see "-onium" in a lot of their names
the ordinary's conditioner has two
percent behentrimonium chloride
in conditioners these cationic surfactants
are usually combined with fatty alcohols
the most common fatty alcohol is cetearyl
alcohol which is a mix of cetyl and stearyl
alcohol these fatty alcohols make the conditioner
thicker so it's easier to apply in your hair
more importantly it also combines with
these cationic surfactants to make
an ordered arrangement called a
lamellar structure this is a bit like
a pile of flat tiles that can slide
over each other and coat the hair
these main ingredients are also why
a lot of people get breakouts on
their back with conditioner cationic
surfactants are quite irritating and
fatty alcohols are pretty good at
clogging pores so if you find you
get a lot of back acne make sure you scrub
your back properly after using conditioner
the ordinary's conditioner is again pretty
simple they've only got seven ingredients
so there's the cationic surfactant and
the fatty alcohol which are the standard
ingredients in every hair conditioner
that form that thin conditioning film
we also have water and just like
in shampoos it's there to make sure
everything is at the right concentration
and thickness for putting on your wet hair
there's also guar gum which
thickens up the formula more
and of course there's preservatives
to control bacteria and mould
with more complex conditioners you
might have extra ingredients and
these change the sorts of
coatings left on the hair
silicones are really common and
there is a huge range of these
some tend to be heavier and people get the
impression that silicones always weigh hair down
but this is not a blanket rule some silicones like
my favorite amodimethicone are charged and so just
like the cationic surfactant you only get a thin
film and any excess stuff actually gets repelled
there are other polymers like polyquaterniums
similar to what's used in shampoos
to detangle and add volume
you might see natural oils like coconut and
argan oil these tend to form thicker films on
hair and this really weighs it down and so usually
they're used at low concentrations in conditioners
you might also have hydrolyzed
proteins and amino acids
these can penetrate into the hair a bit and
add strength by plugging holes in the hair
i was actually quite surprised by
how well this worked on my hair
if you followed my hair bleaching
journey you'll know that i pretty
much need specialized silicones like
amodimethicone to make my hair not be straw
this conditioner detangled my hair really nicely
when i was washing it and it felt nice for about
a day but by day two my hair started feeling a
bit dry i think this would have been fantastic
for my hair before i bleached it but now i
need those extra damage coating ingredients
so i would recommend trying this if your
hair is not quite this level of damaged
if you want a conditioner that doesn't weigh your
hair down or if you want something fragrance free
again there really aren't that many options
for fragrance-free hair conditioners so
i'm really happy to see this as
an option for people who want it
i hope you enjoyed this deep dive
into shampoos and conditioners
let me know if you're interested in other product
breakdowns make sure you like and subscribe
links to the ordinary's hair products are in the
description more videos about cosmetic
science are popping up around me now